[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le lundi 29 janvier voici le programme
de ce soir les agriculteurs en colère
ont repris leur mobilisation aujourd'hui
dans les ivelines deux autoroutes ont
été bloquées la 10 au niveau de
longvilier et la 13 au niveau de Mantel
jolie un blocage qui risque de se
poursuivre le restant de la semaine nos
journalistes étent sur place pour suivre
le mouvement de contestation les
agriculteurs ne sont pas les seuls à
être en colère après l'hôpital de Melan
Les Mureaux il y a 3IS semaine c'est au
tour des soignants de l'hôpital André
mot de crier à l'aide il dénonce
notamment le manque de place pour les
patients qui peuvent rester jusqu'à 5
jours dans un couloir avant d'être
hospitalisé on fait le point sur la
situation en début d'émission le lundi
comme d'habitude nous reviendrons
également sur les résultats sportifs du
weekend football rugby foot US basket ou
encore tir à l'arc ce sera avec notre
journaliste Michael elmidoro sans
oublier l'invité du 78 ce soir le maire
de la commune d'éencour et le président
de l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
iblin Jean-Michel fourgou sera avec nous
pour nous parler des grands projets à
venir en 2024 mais tout de suite retour
sur la mobilisation des agriculteurs
dans les Yvelines la situation se malgré
les annonces du Premier ministre
vendredi dernier l'objectif des
agriculteurs bloquer la capitale pendant
5 jours Nicolas d'Andri et Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude se sont rendus cet
après-midi sur le point de blocage de la
13 les agriculteurs ivelinois de nouveau
mobilisé en ce lundi 29 janvier 2024
vous le voyez dernièr mois le blocage de
la 13 au niveau du pH de bûchel se
prépare dans quelques minutes les
agriculteurs vont s'insérer sur la 13 on
est juste avant
la sortie Mantel jolie centre ils vont
s'insérer sur la 13 et fermer au niveau
de la sortie mantelaville mananville
laissant bloquant ainsi le péage de la
TR au niveau de bûchelet et la sortie
aussi bchel centre commercial et ils
iront ensuite bloquer le sens province
Paris donc la 13 sera fermé au niveau du
péage de bchelet dans les deux cens de
circulation par les agriculteurs
iblinois qui sont de nouveau mobilisés
aujourd'hui
il est 14h30 et ça y est le blocage de
la 13 dans les deux sens de circulation
est effectif ici un agriculteur est en
train de déposer des bottes de paille
pour bloquer l'accès dans le sens Paris
province au total 80 véhicules sont
mobilisés ici sur le péage de bûchelet
des agriculteurs qui viennent du pays
ouané de mante-elajolie de Montfort
lamoris voilà les agriculteurs is
mobilisé et qui maintiennent la pression
sur le gouvernement il y avait 120
propositions qui ont été revend enfin
qui ont été recueilliis par la fnsr sur
les 120 il y en a 10 qui ont été abordés
en fait par les par les par le par
Gabriel Atal vendredi donc on n retrouve
pas nos comptes hein c'est il a abordé
quelques sujets en fait qui concernne la
majorité des agriculteurs qui bloquaient
notamment le GNR par contre surt le
reste de nos revendications rien n'a été
rien n'a été abordé rien n'été entendu
c'est pas normal que on ait des
interdictions entre même pays d'Europe
c'estàd nous on est dans l'Europe on
veut pas sortir de l'Europe mais de
l'autre côté on doit pouvoir produire la
même qualité et la même chose que les
autres pays Européens on nous parle de
souveraineté alimentaire mais mais mais
si on continue comme ça il y a 10 ans on
était 500000 agriculteurs aujourd'hui on
est 300000 dans 10 ans on sera plus que
200000 et et et et l'hémorragie va se
faire comme dans la sidérurgie et le
textile tout tout doucement sans en
silence ça ça ça se meurt gentiment et à
la fin bah on aura perdu notre
souveraineté alimentaire comme on a
perdu pour le textile ouou
l'acier les agriculteurs sont en train
de se mobiliser pour occuper la 13 24h
sur 24 pendant plusieurs jours
d'ailleurs ils sont bien organisés
puisque ils ont mis en place un barbecue
plusieurs tentes avec un téléviseur des
dortoirs ou encore le foot truck pour
s'alimenter derrière moi alors qu'en
pensent les usagers de la 13 on les
écoute on est avec eux hein 1000 à 100 %
quoi on a pas le choix nous aussi il
faut il faut suivre ou pas moi je suis
solidaire je comprends le je comprends
leur mouvement c'est tout c'est tout qui
qui va pas en fait il y a pas que les
paysans blocage c'est embêtant mais bon
après il y a un RB quoi il y a un RB
total donc c'est bien que ça bouge quand
même bah je peux pas aller au travail je
suis obligé de sortir voilà ouais je
comprends ouais je comprends je
comprends très bien ce qu'ils disent il
y a pas de souci les agriculteurs vont
rester mobilisés ici sur la 13 pendant 4
jours jour ils ont fermé et bien un
tronçon de 1000 m entre la sortie
magianville et l'entrée sur la 1ise à
Magnanville direction la province le
péage est encore accessible pour aller
vers la province mais les agriculteurs
du département de l'UR ont fermé au
niveau de Vernon en revanche dans le
sens province Paris le péage de bchelet
est fermé et les usagers que vous voyez
sur le côté ici et bien rentrent à Belet
mais sont contraints de sortir à
magianville et c'est l'heure à présent
de faire le point sur le reste des
informations à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les
Yvelines et c'est avec vous Michel
midoro bonsoir bonsoir On commence ses
informations avec la colère des taxis
après les agriculteurs ce sont
maintenant les chauffeurs de taxis qui
se mobilise ce matin une opération
escargot a eu lieu sur l'autoroute A 13
au départ de mainvillier louvci en
direction de Paris la raison de leur
colère la nouvelle convention avec la
Caisse nationale d'assurance maladie sur
le transport sanitaire qui doit entrer
en vigueur le 1er février elle devrait
modifier les tarifications de la prise
en charge des frais de transport des
patients pour appel actuellement un
chauffeur de taxi peut faire une remise
de 20 % du prix de la course à la
sécurité sociale or avec la nouvelle
convention les professionnels ne
connaissent pas la remise qui pourrait
s'appliquer ni les nouveaux tarifs en
vigueur on poursuit ces informations au
centre hospitalier de Versailles où des
soignants témoignent sur les conditions
de prise en charge des patients aux
urgences dans un dossier de nos
confrères du Parisien trois aid
soignants du centre hospitalier révèle
la faillite de leurs service dans le
long couloir qui traverse les urgences
des brancards santass faute de lit
parfois pendant plusieurs jours on
pouvait lire je cite des témoignages
certains restent jusqu'à 5 jours dans ce
couloir avant d'être hospitalisés où les
aides soignantes sont souvent obligés de
les attachés ces dernières ont découvert
des patients morts tout seuls dans leur
coin des situations qui mettent donc en
danger les patients c'est en tout cas ce
que montre les résultats d'une étude
publiée en septembre et menée dans 97
services d'urgence une nuit à passer
dans un brancard augmente de 40 % le
risque de mortalité des personnes âgées
face à cette situation les syndicats
tirent la sonnette d'alarme pour le
moment sans résultat le musée de la
ville de Saint-Quentin en evveline
devrait fermer ses portes pour les
rouvrir dans un autre lieu de 50 ans en
Éveline prochainement implanté au mumed
un vaste équipement partagé avec la
médiathèque du canal le mus de la ville
devrait changer d'adresse pour cause cet
espace devrait bientôt accueillir
l'école de cybersécurité 2600 qui occupe
actuellement les locaux sous l'escalier
du qui François truffo selon
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Livine le
musée de la ville devrait déménager dans
les prochains mois à la Hal piano futur
quartier des savoirs de guyancour et on
reste à guyancour puisque la ville
organisait pour la première fois ce
weekend une gratiferia qu'est-ce que
c'est une gratifaria Michel le principe
était simple les habitants pouvaient
prendre ce dont ils avaient besoin ou
envie le tout gratuitement livre DVD
objets décoration petits objets
électriques ou électroniques jouets
vessell en passant par des meubles le
choix était large mais limité chaque
personne pouvait choisir entre deux ou
trois objets sur place comme l'explique
au micro de Grégory canalé François
Moron François Morton maèire de guencour
à l'entrée on distribue quatre jetons
trois jetons d'une couleur et un jeton
rouge le jeton rouge permettant d'avoir
accès à une table qui est celle des
objets avec un pe plus de valeur et donc
les personnes peuvent échanger leur
jeton contre un objet de leur
choix des objets qui ont été déposés par
des habitants tout au long de la semaine
dernière parmi les donateurs il y a
marieclaude on l'écoute j'ai déposé un
halogène des petites choses de couture
des rest que j'avais voilà un coussin
aussi pour poser l'ordinateur enfin
voilà des choses dont on avait plus
l'utilité et habituellement on va on va
faire la Ressourcerie mais là c'est
quelque chose je connaissais déjà les
gratiferia et je trouve ça vraiment
formidable que ça ça ça va se développer
peut-être sur lu encour cette initiative
est issue du centre social et de la
responsable du service transition
écologique de la mairie accompagné par
ressourcez-vous gestionnaire de la
Ressourcerie de guancour ainsi que par
le Conseil citoyen de quartier au total
une dizaine de bénévoles ont permis
l'organisation de cette première édition
pour trier et organiser les objets et
comme chaque année samedi la ville de
Rambouillet Élisée sa nouvelle
ambassadrice de la jeunesse rambolitaine
c'était samedi soir et la reine du
muguet 2024 et adrianina Andria Mino har
nozi candidate numéro 2 représenter
l'association des commerçants de
Rambouillet on écoute sa réaction au
micro de Grégory canali je suis vraiment
très surprise ça me fait vraiment très
plaisir et c'est surtout de la joie je
suis vraiment très heureuse pour MRE re
du muget c'est représenter l'association
des commerçants dans les valeurs du
partage et de
l'unité à ses côtés deux autres
candidates ont été élu M zaïz Garmin
première dauphine candidate de
rambouiller sport Basket et Emma Guiry
2e dauphine représentant à l'association
une rose un espoir qui lutte contre le
cancer du sein au total SEP candidates
étaient en LCE on le rappelle chaque
année depuis 1911 rambouillé Ellie une
reine du muguet lors de la nuit du
muguet pendant un an la reine et ses
dauphines deviennent les ambassadrice de
la jeunesse de la ville et tout au long
de leur couronnement elles seront
conviées aux différentes manifestations
organisées par la ville de rambouiller
bien merci beaucoup Michel midoro pour
toutes ces informations comme d'habitude
si vous aussi vous voyez une image ou
une actualité qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news allez comme chaque lundi c'est
l'heure de passer à notre page
[Musique]
sport et on ouvre cette page sport avec
les résultats de ce weekend Mel et on
commence avec du tir à l'arc qui sont
les meilleurs archers des Yvelines plus
de 70 jeunes se sont rencontrés ce
weekend à gu en cours avec un objectif
en vue les régionales dans moins d'une
semaine un reportage de Mélanie poquet
et Patrick Jacques de dixmu ils veulent
être champion du département ce weekend
le club de tir à l'arc de Guill encour
organiser le championnat départemental
jeune des Yvelines pour no championnat
de département on s'aligne sur le
championnat régional c'estàd qu'on
demande aux personnes d'avoir fait au
moins trois concours pour pouvoir se
sélectionner c'est un un honneur de
venir faire un un départemental d'où on
prend pas des gens qui ont des des
scores très très bas on essaie quand
même de garder l'élite du département
pour avoir des bons résultats 14
catégories en arc classique et Arc àouli
étit représenté de U11 à U21 près de 70
jeunes venus de tout le département
correspondaient au critères de sélection
dont la jeune Alicia chambre membre de
l'équipe de France alors Alicia pass
comment très bien
très très bien pour le com oui pour
l'instant ça
vaune oui après le mieux c'est atteindre
c un championnat c'est un championnat il
faut pas le prendre comme si c'était
rien ça fait toujours un entraînement
avec des gens qu'on connaî là l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'était de prendre plaisir
de faire bah comme quand je m'entraîne à
l'entraînement faire un score et voilà
prochain rendez-vous le weekend qui
arrive avec les régionales en scène
Saint-Denis et après le tir à l'arc on
va parler de football et du championnat
de Nationale Versailles a connu une
nouvelle défaite en Nationale les
joueurs de la cité Royal se sont
inclinés ce vendredi 2-1 sur la pelouse
d'Orléan le buteur côté versaillais
Chris Kevin NAD une défaite qui ne fait
pas les affaires des joueurs zivlinois
il se retrouve à la 12e place du
classement avec un bilan de 5 victoires
si Nules et se défaites depuis le début
de la saison prochain match vendredi
prochain sur la pelouse de rouan on
poursuit part du rugby à présent avec le
championnat de fédéral 2 on jouit pour
pour le compte de la 14e journée du
championnat plaisir s'est imposé assez
facilement sur la pelouse d'Antony le
score 32 à 13 le derby evelinois entre
Versailles et maison Lafite s'est
terminé par une victoire du MLSGP sur la
pelouse des Versaillais ils se sont
imposés 24 à 22 sur le fil au classement
plaisir est 3e à 3 points de la première
place Versailles est 9e et le MLSGP est
7e et on passe à un autre sport de
contact du football américain dans le
championnat de 2e division casque d'or
ont joué ce samedi les templier
d'élancour ont pu disputer leur premier
match de la saison à l'extérieur ils se
sont inclinés 29 à 2 sur la pelouse des
servales de ClermontFerrand un match à
sens uni qui ne met pas les élan
courtois dans les meilleures
dispositions au classement ils sont pour
l'instant derniers de leur Pol prochain
match pour les tempillers le 10 février
à domicile contre les mir Midons de
Savini le temple et enfin on termine par
du basket Michel oui Mathilde on joué ce
weekend la 15e journée du championnat de
National 3 trappe s'est imposé 72 à 66
sur le terrain de châau crois ainsi la
3è équipe yvelinoise le chaîné
Versailles a perdu ce samedi soir dans
le gymnase de Vernon le score 89 à 74 au
classement traap est 5e Chatou est 12e
et le chaîn et Versailles 14e et bon
dernier de la poule et on jouit aussi
chez les filles oui Mathilde dans le
championnat de National 2 l'entente le
chaînet Versailles et gagné à domicile
contre Basket Club chevon le score 66 à
51 les iilinois sont à la 2uxe place du
classement à un point de la première
place et bien merci beaucoup
michelmidoro pour toutes ces
informations sportives on vous retrouve
comme d'habitude lundi prochain lundi
prochain pour une nouvelle page sport
c'est bientôt l'heure de l'invité du 7 h
mais avant je vous propose de jeter un
coup d'œil à la météo de
demain j'espère que vous avez bien
profité du soleil parce que la grisaille
sera de retour demain le matin prévoyez
même quelques averse côté température
compté en moyenne 8°g sur l'ensemble des
evelines et dans l'après-midi la pluie
sera toujours bien présente dans tout le
département il fera 10°gr à
mant-elajolie et rambouillé et 11 à
Houdan et versaill et demain nous
fêterons la sainte-mtine c'est l'heure à
présent de l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et l'invité du 78 ce soir c'est le
maire d'élancour et le président de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Eveline Jean-Michel Fourgous bonsoir
bonsoir bonne année 2024 écoutez vous
aussi pour tout pour tout Saint-Quentin
et votre télévision meroup bonne année
également à tous les habitants
d'élancour alors avant de parler de 2024
je vous propose de faire un retour brief
sur l'année 2023 qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de cette année
écoulée sur hancourou sur Saint-Quentin
les deux bah s sur 5501 c'est la
mobilisation très forte pour quatre
sites olympiques ce qui est énorme déjà
un donc par exemple sur aencour bien sûr
on vit celui de la colline d'élencour on
s'est disputter pendant 20 ans pour pour
se mettre d'accord sur un projet bon ça
y est on l'a bon c'est un beau projet
donc donc voilà tout ça ça développe
l'esprit sportif qui élu qui n'arrve pas
d'augmenter les pratiques sportives de
ses administrés donc c'est quand même un
petit peu le cas en plus bien sûr ça ça
déclenche un plan de construction
supplémentaire de piste cyclable de on
va passer 450 km qui est énorme déjà un
peu sur une gllomération à 600 km en
plus dans des environnemies très verts
enfin très donc très agréable donc c'est
vraiment un très beau projet
euh donc et puis bon bien sûr 600
bénévoles qui qui se sont proposés de
participer parce que c'est un événement
qui va recevoir 350000 personnes c'est
c'est quand même c'est quand même énorme
euh donc voilà donc tout le monde est
heureux de voir bien sûr son
agglomération sont les 12 villes qui
sont quand même directement directement
concerné
donc la préparation des des Jio pour
l'année 2023 c'est prê c'est prêt autre
événement qui a marqué l'année 2023
Jean-Michel forgou ce sont les émeutes
urbaines qui ont sont survenus début de
l'été 2023 l'agglomération de 50 ans
nielin a été fortement touchée quel
bilan tirez-vous de cette
événement écoutez on on regarde
l'augmentation par exemple de l'inséc
été sur sur 2023 hein bon euh en chiffre
enfin il y a une augmentation de de 10 %
en France la sécurité sur 2023 elle est
7 % sur 5 Quentin donc elle est quand
même meilleure entre guillemets mais il
demeure que c'est les villes où il y
avait le plus de commerces qui ont été
touché celles qui ont une gare aussi qui
sont bien entendu euh donc justement
vous avez mis en place des aides pour
les commerçants absolument euh avec que
nos partenaires traditionnels on on a la
chance d'avoir des partenaires puissants
on a bien sûr la Région le Département
euh donc c'est vrai que ça ça nous a
permis de de de faire des montages pour
aider nos commerçants qui étaient quand
dont certains ont été quand même
beaucoup touché sur après la crise du du
covid déjà qui avait été très coûteuse
bon on s'en serait bien passé quoi c'est
sûr que on lance un appel à la
responsabilisation et des parents et des
enfants regardez la verrière ils ont
démolis de il y avait trois écoles à La
Verrière ils ont démoli deux ils ont
démoli l'école de leurs petits frères
leurs petites sœur mais vous pouvez
m'expliquer là comment ça fonctionne bon
j'ai pas compris mais bon quand vous
êtes élu vous voilà il faut trouver
l'argent il faut trouver sur les moyens
c'est l cononst une école c'est c'est
c'est coûteux pour tout le monde voilà
on a on a plein de choses à régler plus
important que ça redonner du pouvoir
d'achat enfinmenter pouir d'achat des
gens je sais pas avoir plus de moyens
pour se soigner pour faire de la
recherche contre le CAC parce qu'on a
besoin de mettre de l'argent comme ça
voilà vous s on le prend quelque part
quand on met sur des choses qui il y a
une inutilité totale dans ses travaux
mais bon-ce c'est c'est la société c'est
son évolution alors justement on va
parler de de travaux dans les grands
projets pour l'année 2024 à hencour
Jean-Michel Fourgous il y a la
rénovation du quartier des petits prix
qu'est-ce qui est prévu
concrètement là c'est c'est
effectivement quartier important à é
encour mais on y met 50 millions donc ce
qui est énorme bien sûr
euh donc c'est c'est en fait c'est la
rénovation c'est la construction d'une
école c'est bien sûr un environnement
plus vert plus sécurisé bien sûr plus
plus facile
à bien sûr à à à communiquer je veux
dire que c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est très bien c'est assez exceptionnel
bien
sûr mais c dit ça méritait ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait pas fait des
travaux voilà on en fait là on en fait
la clé de Saint-Pierre aussi on met on
met on met je crois 4 millions sur la cl
de Saint-Pierre on met 4 millions sur
sur le village avec le la rénovation du
tout ce qui était autour du bassin de la
me qui est très joli euh donc donc voilà
il y a il y a on a on a rénové enfin on
a on a refait une nouvelle piscine il y
a y a quelques temps on est en train de
faire les travaux sur sur l' 10 qui
coûte très cher c'est pas de 150
millions bon vous imaginez bon après il
y aura le le le pont de la Villedieu
parce qu'il y a trop d'encomement le
matin et il faut mais on doit attendre
de finir la nationalise avant de faire
bien sûr on avait déjà modernisé la la
gare aussi donc il y a beaucoup de de
travaux bien entendu de de modernisation
pour qu' a plus de confort plus de
sécurité aujourd'hui il y a une demande
de sécurité quand même mais que l'on
sent et et on y répond al on y répond
bien s par un projet que vous connaissez
bon voilà cette année sera également axé
sur les mobilités 12 vous en avez un
petit peu parlé dans les projets au tout
début queles sont les principaux axes
qui vont changer alors il y a il y a
quelque chose original c'est que vous
pourrez faire avec en vélo avec vos
enfants le le tour des quatre sites
olympiques puisque il y a une P GL qui
va relier qui commence d'ailleurs je
crois relier déjà les quatre plus la
gare donc de de Saint-Quentin Montini
donc bien sûr ça va être assez
sympathique puis regardez les pistes
qu'il y a dans dans l'île de loisir
aussi puisque il y a il y a trois sites
comme qui sont très proches de l'Î de
loisirs bon c'est c'est vrai que c'est
une belle une belle petite révolution
même pour le ce qu'on appelle le dernier
kilomètre c'est les gens qui viennent
travailler ils arrivent à la gare mais
il y a le dernier kilomètre alors bien
sûr il y a des vélos il y a des
trottinettes donc bien entendu ça met un
ça met un peu d'ambiance très
sympathique pour aller travailler mais
aussi surtout pour aller se balader ça
pousse à à faire du sport ce que je vous
tout à l'heure bon voilà donc c'est on
est très content de se lapisser la
capitale du vélo du coup avec les Jeux
Olympiques donc de toute façon on n pas
le choix mais moi ça PL je fais du vélo
aussi he vous savez mais mais ça donne
des des envie de faire du vélo à plus de
gens oui une école du numérique devrait
également voir le jour à la Commanderie
d'lancour où est-ce qu'on est ce dossier
alors d'abord ici on est beaucoup dans
l'innovation à
Saint-Quentin l'innovation sur le modèle
scolaire parce que les résultats de
pizza vous connaissez c'est quand même
assez c'est c'est quand même c'est quand
même difficile on les comparaisons bien
s internationale on souhaite améliorer
ce modèle scolaire qui n'a pas beaucoup
évolué depuis 50 ans et je pense que les
pratiques la vie évolué la façon de de
travailler de de lire de de d'écrire de
d'échanger et et donc voilà on a un
modèle scolaire qui est qui est très
innovant qui d'ailleurs a été envoyé par
la France à l'Exposition
universelle de Dubaï donc donc h très
fort modèle prototype un peu de la de
l'école du futur
également également
euh également de la sécuritéin vous
savez puisqu'on travaille sur le
prototype de de de de la sécurité du
futur mais pour envenir à l'éducation la
Commanderie la Commanderie effectivement
des Templiers
va être bien sûr utilisé pour lancer ce
ce ce ce laboratoire très innovant qui
vous pousse à d'abord à à à à mieux
comprendre cette fracture numérique et
et et à la combler parce que demain
votre niveau de le niveau de richesse
d'un pays de production de richesse d'un
pays va dépendre de de sa culture
numérique euh 85 % des métiers de demain
n'existe pas aujourd'hui donc d'ici 2035
donc il il va falloir quand même faire
bouger un peu no nos lignes sur le plan
culturel et la culture scientifique est
aujourd'hui même je comprend pas que les
dirigeants souvent bon dirigeant
politique doit avoir une culture
scientifique doit avoir une culture
économique une culture
technique voilà c'est c'est scientifique
économique numérique technique c'est
c'est indispensable les problèmes de
demain ils sont c'est bien de faire un
doctorat sur Victor Hugo moi je suis
docteur en psychologie c'est bien mais
bon enfin j'ai fait d'R diplôm mais faut
faut aujourd'hui avoir vraiment une
compréhension des des des mécanismes
tout ça va être réfléchi à la
commanderieou dans la Commanderie et
puis vous êtes dans Paris SACL Paris
SACL c'est quand même vous êtes dans les
h territoires les plusnevants au monde
vous avez la première université
[Musique]
scientifique au monde mathématique hein
qui Paris sa cl avec d'ailleurs 550 qui
est qui est dans dans dans Paris sa-clay
donc voilà on est dans dans dans ce dans
ces objectifs élevés pour pour tout les
entreprises elles sont demandeur les
entreprises elles ont besoin de de
aujourd'hui elles sont de plus en plus
numériques elles ont besoin de
compétences de leur ajouter et cetera
donc faut il faut on se bas nous sur la
formation des talents c'est le le
premier talent c'est de savoir trouver
les talent les développer et donc on est
en terme de formation on a des des très
bonnes grandes écoles vous le savez
bon SaintQuentin et Paris SACL et pour
pour vraiment garder donner permettre
aux entreprises d'avoir d'avoir le
meilleur voilà le mieux formé et on se
batus c'est un des axes bien sûr et la
Commanderie ce projet de la Commanderie
en fait partie alors au niveau de la
culture nous avons eu l'information
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui Jean-Michel
Fourgous on en a parlé en début
d'émission le musée de la ville situé
derrière le théâtre de Saint-Quentin en
Eveline devrait
déménager est-ce que le
dossier va aller où est-ce que le
dossier va écoutez pour l'instant ce
dossie n'est pas arbitré il y a un
besoin de l'école 2600 qui est un
aujourd'hui qui a une croissance et
c'est plutôt bon signe et c'est c'est
une une école qui a emporte les premiers
prix un peu dans dans surtout tout ce
qui est cybersécurité qui est un axe en
plein développement et donc il faut
qu'on trouve bien sûr à à à à à ils sont
juste à côté il faut qu'on trouve des
locaux alors donc c'est évoqué mais de
toute façon à ce momentl le le musée de
la ville irait dans d'autres locaux qui
seraient qui seraiit aussi sinon plus
confortable et même même je crois avec
plus de place mais on c'est à l'étude
pour l'instant il y a pas de décision
définitive alors toujours à 50 an
Éveline de nombreux projets il y a
beaucoup de grands travaux en ce moment
au sein de l'agglomération la rénovation
de l'hypercentre de Montini le parc du
lac à voisin le projet garbecane à
Laverrière est-ce qu'on peut parler de
cquentins nivenu en transition en
transition écoutez certainement il
transition numérique il a la transition
écologique a même urbanistiquement
parlant il y a il y a des bâtiments
aujourd'hui qui se construisent pour les
entreprises parce que le le le le covid
a un peu transformé la société donc
voilà et et les
locaux ont un peu changé le
l'utilisation de de ces locaux aussi les
les types d'outil sur lequels ils
travaillent à distance ou en présentiel
bon donc on doit tenir compte de ça et
toujours on travaille dans ce qu'on
appelle la Smart City c'est-à-dire la
ville de demain et c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses on est en plein
changement on travaille avec des des
urbanistes bien sûr très innovants et et
mais mais on est obligé Saint-Quentin
aujourd'hui une image assez
forte de de de de en France et on est à
à on est à 30 minutes hors encombrement
euh 30 minutes de de Paris sans feu
rouge c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel bon oui euh on voit bien
que la demande continue malgré la crise
on a une trip une quadruple crisez la
crise géopolitique économique après
celle sanitaire
écologique
euh
m migratoire parce qu'on on nous parle
beaucoup de de tous ces sujets de de
sécurité tout on on on doit la société
il quand même vit des moments difficiles
euh donc cette cette cette société on la
on doit on la dessine avec euh avec des
des gens très innovants et mais sou
Saint-Quentin est pas en retard je peux
vous dire sur la transformation bien sûr
des quartiers des et des et des des
habitations et et des entre et des lieux
d'entreprise oui également et même des
universités puisque aussi former former
au savoir de demain formmer au aux
nouvelles technologies aux compétences
de haute valeur ajoutées sur des
secteurs stratégiques hein qutin vise
des secteurs très stratég il a également
les transports puisque la future ligne
18 va passer par Saint-Quentin en
Eveline qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour
l'agglomération cette future ligne 18
cette ligne 18 elle va elle va relier
bien sûr
Saint-Quentin beaucoup plus directement
avec Orly avec avec Paris donc compte
tenu de de la du
niveau d'entreprise niveau de de
laboratoire édé de très haute valeur
ajoutée je vous rappelle qu'on a un PIB
près de 30 milliards sur 50 ans on
noccupe que 5 % du territoire des
ielines et je vous dis on a le même PIB
par habitant que que les Américains bon
ça quand même c'est quand même
impressionnant bon donc il faut qu'on
qu'on puisse avoir les meilleures voies
de de je dirais de de de d'échange de de
de de les gens veulent gagner du temps
dans les transports mais en toute façon
il a il y a la voiture autonome qui se
prépare dans les 5 ans vous aurez la
voiture autonome en plus comme vous a un
axe à 13 à 12 autoroute sans feu rouge
qui arrive à Saint-Quentin sans feu
rouge bon il y a il y a beaucoup de il y
a beaucoup de moyens il y a de vraiment
de gros investissements qui sont faits
avec la région de France bien sûr sur
comment améliorer encore plus les bien
sûr les les les les la mobilité et et et
et surtout répondre à ce fameux
aussi ce qu'on appelle le dernier
kilomètre quand vous arrivez à la GU
voilà enfin Saint-Quentin est est pas en
retard là-dessus ça coûte cher euh tout
ce qui est transport mais l'innovation
elle est partout elle est à l'université
ici elle est dans l'écologie dans le
sport aussi dans le futur commissariat
alors dans le futur commissariat
absolument alors qu'estce que ça va
apporter alors ce n commissari ce sera
ce sera bien sûr un ce sera pour pour
mieux coordonner les forces il a il y a
donc 360
policiers il y a trois villes qui sont
trois commissariats Guill en cour trappe
et lcour bon c'est plus coordonné des
forces des moyens aussi des moy trs trs
innant alors il va falloir que vous
fassiez une émission pour ça si vous
voulez que je donne tout tout ce qui
dans ce commissariat pour
transformer transformer d'abord la façon
dont on reçoit une victime dont on la
traite comment on travaille avec la
justice comment les policiers peuvent
être plus sur le terrain comment ils
peuvent être plus sécurisés parce que
quand on voit qu'il a 13000 blessés chez
les
policiers comment voulez-vous maintenir
c'est quand Mme une mission c'est quand
même on a besoin de polici mais qui qui
va aller se faire recruter vous dis vous
accepteriez un poste où il y a 13000
blessés par par an enfin il faut donc il
faut renforcer la sécurité des policier
renforcer leur rapidité d'intervention
de de de de de de de de communication
entre eux de de et puis il y a aussi
bien sûr beaucoup beaucoup de hautes
technologies aujourd'hui qui ont qui
font font faire des des bons au au au ce
qu'on appelle un peu l' sécurité qui qui
est effectivement une vraie réion comme
li éducation comme li santé demain
d'ailleurs on on on travaille aussi sur
l'hôpital du futur euh donc vous voyez
on est très on la transition numérique
on veut on veut vraiment d'abord former
les gens aussi à cel parce qu'il y en a
qui regardent ça avec beaucoup de
distance mais on n' pas le choix demain
c'est leur sécurité c'est c'est c'est
l'éducation c'est le le leur 6 s'en
nuuit à la maison de pouvoir travailler
sur une tablette mais il y a il y a le
monde vous voyez le monde entier
aujourd'hui c'est extraordinaire vous
même amuser donc il faut vraiment faire
passer ce ce ce cette phase à à nos à
nos à même à nos seigneors à à nos
enfants bien sûr sur surt les métiers
que je viens je viens de vous évoquer
mais même la recherche médicale je pense
que s'il y avait pas eu le numérique la
la la la le le vir l'antivirus le le
vaccin qu'on a trouvé en 6 mois on l'a
fait parce qu'il y avait des échanges
grâce au numérique entre tous les
laboratoires du monde entier donc
aujourd'hui euh voilà c'est une vraie
révolution et Saint-Quentin qui est dans
dans dans l'innovation vraiment notre
ADN c'est l'innovation nous alors je
vous propose qu'on termine par le sport
Jean-Michel Fourgous dans quelques mois
hlencour et Saint-Quentin en evveline
vous l'avez dit en début de cette
interview vont accueillir les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 il y aura du
vélo et du BMX à Montini du golf à
guencour et du VTT à hencour comment ça
se prépare des Jeux Olympiques à 50 ans
en Eveline alors d'abord nous on est
très très à mettre en avant aussi les
les valeurs du sport parce que on a pris
ces quatre év qui sont quand même on
leur coûpt encore que c'est pas
forcément Saint-Quentin qui s'écoutte le
plus ch mais c'est les
valeurs un un jeune qui qui qui par
enfin un jeune il veut bon il veut
réussir comme vous parlez avec lui mais
mais attends il faut que tu apprennes
d'abord à être arrivé à l'heure
euh à l'entraînement tu vois ça commence
par ça à respecter ton entraîneur à
respecter ton ton ton ton ton adversaire
le le le le le juge aussi bon donc et
puis il faut que tu apprennes la méthode
de travail la
méthode de la durabilité de l'effort
parce que faire un effort pendant 5
minutes voilà c'est c'est ça et c'est
ces valeurs qui font gagner dans la vie
c'est ces gagneurs qui font gagner dans
l'entreprise donc on on on on rappelle
bien toutes ces toutes ces valeurs qui
qui qui qui sont à l'origine du bonheur
de la réussite voilà et on est content
d'avoir ces ces Jos pour bien montrer
enfin c'est un booster de c'est un
booster de de de de valeur et et et
c'est un accélérateur de pratique
sportive bon c'est bien sûr c'est c'est
un accélérateur de croissance aussi de
de de de
transformation on le voit sur la colline
on aurait jamais pu ça faisait 20 ans
Savit pas quoi faire de cette cine qui
quand même fait 50 hectares bon et ben
c'est grâce c'est grâce au G puis il y a
des recettes il y a des recettes quand
même a entre 7 et 10 milliards de
recettes économiques donc ça booste
l'économie et la notoriété de
Saint-Quentin comme on l'a vu avec la
rider Cup qui est une grande grande
compétition de golf ça a été assez assez
impressionant chance à 50 Anseline
d'avoir de de beau site olympique alors
pour terminer Jean-Michel forgous on
vous laisse une carte blanche de 30
secondes environ vous pouvez aborder le
sujet que vous voulez bah écoutez euh je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les les les les les
Français d'une façon générale nous
administré de 1 mais d'abord faut qu'ils
prenne conscience que ils ont ils ont
beaucoup de choses ils ont beaucoup de
chances mais même sur le plan écologique
c'est c'est quand même la ville à la
campagne voyez c'est c'est c'est ils ont
une qualité de l'air une qualité de
l'eau quand même assez exceptionnelle
ils ont euh euh des des des un nombre
d'équipements sportifs qui est en norme
bon à à à à à à moins de 30 minutes de
la plus belle capitale du monde bon s
fou bon voilà ils ont ils ont un
problème ils ont un hôpital don donc
quand même en 5 minutes ils ont euh ils
ont euh ils ont accès des magasins euh
voilà il y a il y a y a des y a des
grandes surfaces des moyennes surfaces
il y a il y a il y a puis une vie
collective entre les 12 communes qui
fonctionnent ça fonctionne Saint-Quentin
je vous dis pas que tentend un petit
désaccord sur un un dossier mais
globalement il y a plutôt une bonne
ambiance euh c'est c'est c'est il y a un
T d'insécurité qui est plus faible bien
sûr que qu'en France et on va encore
donner bien sûr une initation avec le le
commissaire du futur les écoles elles
sont euh elles sont à un très haut
niveau vous le savez je que du du du du
de de du primaire l'école primaire on
apprend différemment
effectivement à Saint-Quentin jusqu'à
l'université qui qui numé un première
université scientifique mondiale en
mathématiqueag donc euh euh on on est on
n'est pas malheureux mais mais il faut
on aimerait que toute la France et ce ce
même euh ce ce ce c'est parce qu'on a
une culture de l'innovation faut pas
vous tromper l'innovation c'est la
remise en cause de l'existant peu de
gens osent remettre en cause l'existant
et je pense qu'il faut aller il faut
bien comendre que le monde de demain il
est tellement en transformation et donc
cette culture euh est quand même assez
assez fascinante à Saint-Quentin et à
Paris ça Clad hein bien sûr c'est merci
beaucoup Jean-Michel forgou je suis
désolée on a un peu pris par le temps on
va devoir rendre l'antenne merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau
encore une fois une belle année 2024 à
hlencour et à Saint-Quentin en Yveline
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur tv78 demain rendez-vous
avec Grégory canal et pour l'édition
prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous